und wohnt ihr noch oder verzweifelt ihr
schon das sind die aktuellen mietpreise
2021 in deutschland 18 eur 48 pro
quadratmeter in münchen 15 75 in
frankfurt und 13 68 in berlin für
neuvertragsmieten was ist los auf dem
wohnungsmarkt mega fusion von
immobilienkonzernen hier demos für
enteignungen dort was macht eigentlich
die politik fragt ihr euch vielleicht
und wer war noch mal der verantwortliche
bundesbauminister ich kann euch das
sagen ich habe ihn getroffen bauminister
ist horst seehofer und der lobt sich vor
allem selbst also ich bin sehr zufrieden
anderer in der regierung sehen das
übrigens ganz anders wird den eindruck
erweckt es gebe kein problem mit den
mieten und mit den knappen und fehlenden
wohnraum für diejenigen die nur ganz
normale einkünfte haben oder sogar sehr
wenig verdient denn er redet sich die
welt schön und überblickt die probleme
nicht die wir wirklich haben eine groko
zwei meinungen ist denn vielleicht schon
wahlkampf und was gilt denn nun ist
alles horst seehofer super oder olaf
scholz schlimm
schenk mir ein paar minuten eurer zeit
und ich erzähle euch was ich hier bei
politikern gerade für krasse
ideologische fronten beim thema mieten
bauen wohnen erlebe und warum der
bauminister wenig grund hat zum selbst
mein name ist andrea maurer ich bin
politische korrespondentin im zdf
hauptstadtstudio und beschäftige mich
schon lange mit dem thema mieten bauen
wohnen es geht darum wie wir leben wie
unsere städte aussehen wer sich wo noch
eine wohnung leisten kann das betrifft
uns ja eigentlich alle deshalb
diskutiert sehr gerne mit unten in den
kommentaren
schreibt was ihr so erlebt auf dem
deutschen mietmarkt oder wie ihr die
probleme lösen würde denn eigentlich
sind wir uns doch alle einig bezahlbaren
wohnraum den brauchen wir dringend das
sehen auch schließe 3 übrigens so aber
was hat unsere regierung dafür getan
[Musik]
horst seehofer wohnt bekanntlich im
ministerium selbst wenn er zum arbeiten
in berlin ist im bunker hat das der
spiegel mal genannt ob horst seehofer
die miet- und wohnprojekte in
deutschland aus eigener anschauung kennt
das wage ich zu bezweifeln
ich habe ihn mal im april zu einem sehr
seltenen interview getroffen er gibt
eigentlich quasi gar keine interviews
und dieses interview begann dann erstmal
nur eine frage herr seehofer nice try es
gibt tatsächlich ziemlich viele fragen
an den bundesbauminister oder glaubt er
wirklich er hat alles richtig gemacht
wir haben das größte wohnungsbauprogramm
aufgelegte in der jüngeren geschichte
deutschlands und wir werden alle ziele
erreichen vom sozialen wohnungsbau über
den frei finanzierten wohnungsbau über
das baukindergeld dreimalige wohngeld
erhöhungen für die geringeren
einkommensklassen und jetzt noch am
schluss ein bauland mobilisierungs
gesetz das im bundestag abschließend
beraten wird also ich bin sehr zufrieden
typisch seehofer das war eigentlich die
antwort auf alle meine fragen er hat
alles richtig gemacht für einen beitrag
in berlin direkt habe ich aber mal die
fakten recherchiert
die zahl der sozialwohnungen geht weiter
zurück 43.000 wohnungen fallen jedes
jahr aus der sozialbindung neu hinzu
kommen nur etwa 25.000 jährlich größtes
versprechen 1,5 millionen neu gebaute
wohnungen bis zum ende der legislatur
1,2 millionen werden es sein politisches
ziel um 300.000 wohnungen verfehlen ihr
habt ihn noch im ohr oder ich bin sehr
zufrieden wie groß die probleme auf dem
deutschen wohnungsmarkt weiter sind und
bleiben das allerdings zeigen solche
meldungen mieten in deutschland steigen
anfang 2000 21 massiv an der mietanstieg
setzt sich trotz corona ungebremst fort
wohnen ist immer noch für viele deutsche
zu teuer und deutlicher preisanstieg
erreicht auch die deutschen speckgürtel
alle parteizentralen haben das thema
mieten bauen wohnen für den wahlkampf
übrigens voll auf dem schirm auch olaf
scholz der spd-kanzlerkandidat der für
ein interview zum thema eigentlich immer
auf verfügung steht es ist zeit zu
handeln und es muss gehandelt werden
sagt wohlgemerkt der vizekanzler dieser
regierung der hatte doch eigentlich viel
zeit zum handeln oder wie seht ihr das
die ideologischen fronten die sich da
gerade auch politisch auftun lassen sich
übrigens am besten hier in der
hauptstadt beobachten am sogenannten
mieten deckel disaster
[Musik]
was mieten technisch gerade in berlin
passiert das jedenfalls kein großstadt
hipster problem das kommt vielleicht
auch auf andere deutsche groß und
mittelstädte zu immerhin geht heute
jeder siebte haushalt in deutschen
städten als durch die miete überlastet
das sind immerhin 11,4 millionen
menschen die mehr als 40 prozent ihres
monatseinkommens für miete ausgeben
müssen 40 prozent vor allem aber es ist
der ton den ich hier gerade in der
mieten decke geschichte bei vielen
politikern höhere der echt nichts gutes
für den wahlkampf und die stimmung im
land verheißt es war eine kampfansage
der mieten deckel anfang letzten jahres
berlin als bühne für den großen
ideologischen schlagabtausch ganz klares
signal dass wir ernst machen mit der
sicherung des grundrechts auf wo es geht
um eine zutiefst sozial politische frage
dieser senat hat um berlin herum wieder
eine mauer gebaut das ist der größte
tabubruch der jüngsten geschichte totale
uneinigkeit und das paradoxe der mieten
deckel hat die knappheit erst mal
verschärft
ihr habt sicher mitbekommen cdu und fdp
abgeordnete hatten in karlsruhe gegen
den mieten decke geklagt und viele
eigentümer waren verunsichert oder
wollten das urteil aus karlsruhe
abwarten die logik des marktes wie ein
makler mal ganz unumwunden in das mikro
meiner kollegin sylvia bleßmann gesagt
hat wir haben fast alle eigentümer
geraten die noch nicht vermietet haben
die wohnung entweder zu verkaufen oder
leer stehen zu lassen kammern oder so
klingt dann eigentum verpflichtet
dringend gebrauchten wohnraum dem
mietmarkt einfach entziehen
am ende hat das verfassungsgericht
gesagt der mieten decke muss bundesweit
gelten oder gar nicht und damit war das
thema dann endgültig ein schlachtfeld
für den bundeswahlkampf wenn ihr wissen
wollt wie radikal es bei dem thema noch
werden kann
dann schaut nach berlin denn was ich
hier auch politiker liefern ist ein
echter häuserkampf
[Musik]
der berliner häuserkampf ist inzwischen
echt heftig und zwar nicht nur unter den
autonomen in berlin-friedrichshain
sondern auch unter politikern selbst das
büro des cdu abgeordneten jan marco
luczak der in karlsruhe die klage gegen
den berliner mieten deckel auf den weg
gebracht hat demoliert und beschmiert er
hat die fotos selbst auf twitter
veröffentlicht auch dieses foto das
kevin kühnert ein spd politiker zeigt
wie er vor lux büro demonstriert auf
seinem plakat einheit für mieter was man
dazu wissen muss beide kämpfen um das
direktmandat im berliner stadtteil
tempelhof schöneberg ich habe kevin
kühnert mal gefragt ob das jetzt der
neue wahlkampfstil ist und warum er jan
marco luczak zum metall macht das sind
seine freunde die wir dort aufgezeigt
haben und das ist sicherlich eine
zuspitzung aber das kann man schon
rechtfertigen luther gesetzt für die
berliner cdu im bundestag und die
berliner cdu hat jüngst von herrn brüner
im großen immobilieninvestor eine
800.000 euro spende 800.000 euro das
sind keine peanuts
der eine geht mit enteignungs
befürwortern auf die straße der andere
kungelt mit mieten das sind die neuen
fronten das wird ein spannender
wahlkampf wie hat der clash inzwischen
ist hat sich am 23
mai in berlin gezeigt häuserkampf in der
nacht als am potsdamer platz tausende
für den mieten deckel und sogar für die
enten der großen wohnungskonzern
demonstrieren vereinbaren zeitgleich in
einem der hochhäuser die immobilien
giganten bono via und deutsche wohnen
eine mega-fusion hier unten in der
infobox findet ihr einen link zu den
hintergründen des deals was sich daran
auch bezeichnen finde
je mehr marktmacht desto größer das
gehör der politik übrigens auch in kevin
kühnert spd berlins sozialdemokratische
bürgermeister michael müller jedenfalls
scheint sehr zufrieden mit dem deal den
das kartellamt noch abnicken muss jetzt
darf er wohl 20.000 wohnungen von wo
novia deutsche wohnen kaufen wenn es
stimmt was das manager magazin berichtet
für drei bis fünf milliarden euro am
ende würde es also den steuerzahler 3
bis 5 milliarden euro kosten das michael
müller seinen wahlversprechen hält
wieder mehr wohnung in städtischer hand
michael müller
gerne der nächste bundesbauminister sein
soviel dazu ihr seht einfach ist nichts
auf dem deutschen wohnungsmarkt und wir
haben noch gar nicht über die ihren
bodenpreise differenten baukosten und so
viel mehr gesprochen
auch dass ich eigentlich immer weniger
menschen eigentum überhaupt noch leisten
können gleich jedenfalls ist es bleibt
eine menge zu tun für den nächsten
bauminister oder die nächste baum
ministerin
denn ihr habt vielleicht schon gelesen
der jetzige freut sich im herbst auf den
ruhestand
[Musik]
hier meine persönliche top 3 to do liste
für den nächsten mann oder die nächste
frau im bauministerium
erstens mehr sozialer wohnungsbau
unbedingt unser aller horror muss doch
verdrängung sein und schlafstätte wie in
frankreich also solche vororte in die
menschen nur zum schlafen fahren
zweitens immobilienkonzerne in die
soziale pflicht nehmen und
privatvermieter starten
drittens weniger ideologie mehr konzepte
weniger selbstlob mehr selbstkritik
also ich bin sehr zufrieden wenn ihr
mich fragt brauchen wir in zukunft auch
ein eigenständiges bauministerium nicht
so wie jetzt wo es am innenministerium
dranhängt dazu habe ich horst seehofer
däninnen heimat und bauminister übrigens
auch gefragt also wer wird da politisch
die axt angelegt und sagt jetzt tun sich
alle raus in ein gleichnis ministerium
mit ein paar hundert leuten der schwächt
die durchschlagskraft des themas also
horst seehofer ist nicht dafür alles
horst seehofer super gelaufen mit seinem
ministerium
ich will aber mal wetten das nächste
bauministerium wird eigenständig so groß
wie das thema im wahlkampf ist wird es
auch in den koalitionsverhandlungen
seien eines kann ich euch auf jeden fall
versprechenden germany's next
bauminister germany's next bau
ministerin werde ich auf jeden fall sehr
oft fragen was er oder sie für mehr
bezahlbaren wohnraum in deutschland tut
schreibt uns gerne unten in den
kommentaren abonniert doch unseren kanal
inside politics da lassen wir
korrespondenten und korrespondentinnen
aus dem zdf hauptstadtstudio euch
regelmäßig hinter die kulissen der
politik gucken jedes video lohnt sich